foreign
[Music]
hi there welcome to the latest AI video
from Google Cloud today we're going to
take a look at how to integrate
generative AI into our applications
without requiring much setup generative
AI app builder allows you to create
applications focused around search and
chat experiences with minimal coding
required this video will focus on how to
bring the power of search to your
applications
one of the most challenging problems to
solve for an organization can be
discoverability of information many
times data will be scattered across a
bunch of different sources some might be
in docs some might be in databases
others and web pages this makes it
difficult for employees and customers to
find just what they're looking for
whether it be internal data or on a
public site let's get started by looking
at the onboarding experience one of the
useful features of gen app builder is
its ease of use for Developers
we'll go through the process of setting
up a basic search engine for a public
website structured data and unstructured
data
first you go to the generative AI app
builder section in the Google Cloud
console
then you enable the API
then you select create a search engine
then you give it a name and choose the
data type let's go through the website
process first
after our search engine has been created
we just need to add the sites we want to
include
if we open the advanced view then we can
exclude certain sites as well for this
example let's search over the Google
Cloud website cloud.google.com
after setting the website we now have a
view of the URLs included in our search
engine you can also add more websites if
you want
and just that fast the search engine has
already indexed our website we can now
click on preview search to try it out
the preview page lets you try out your
search engine in a browser you can
select a desktop or mobile view
a search for another Google Cloud
product document AI shows lots of
relevant results for the product we can
also look for more detailed information
like how to handle nested entities with
document AI now let's go back and create
a new search engine this time for
structured data you can import the data
from cloud storage in a structured
format like Json or from a bigquery
table
let's import data from bigquery we'll
use a public data set of movies that can
be found on kaggle importing the data
requires very little setup because the
tool will figure out the schema for you
you just eat the data in and it'll work
once it finishes importing we can test
the search engine out just like the
previous one
the process for unstructured data works
pretty similar to structured data
unstructured data doesn't follow a
schema usually this will be in the form
of documents like PDFs
you create a search engine for
unstructured data then you can import
files from cloud storage
in this case I'm importing alphabet
earnings reports once they're imported
you can search through the files to find
specific information now we've explored
the main types of search engines let's
see how we can use them in our
applications if we go to the integration
pane the console provides simple ways to
integrate this new search engine into an
application you can go to the API tab to
get pre-written API calls and code
samples to integrate this into server
applications or build your own UI
or you can copy paste HTML code in the
widget tab to embed this directly into
your website go into the configure menu
from this page takes you to the widget
settings where you can configure
autocomplete among other features for
your search engine widget for structured
data we can also control more specific
settings such as the fields that are
shown in the widget like movie title
description ratings and add a thumbnail
image
the analytics page provides aggregate
metrics for the search engine including
session information click-through rate
top queries and devices
as we've discussed Enterprise search
gives you an out of the box developer
experience whether it's web pages
tabular data or documents like PDF files
you can just bring them in Enterprise
search automatically builds the schema
and search index for your data with a
simple UI flow if you're super excited
to get started go to The Trusted testers
page on the Google Cloud website to
apply for Early Access once you have
access you can follow the guide Linked
In the description to get started
building your first search engine
app builder will be publicly available
later this year thank you very much for
watching and stay tuned for our next
video about generative AI
foreign